Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the book of purification of the
chapters regarding
and we have arrived today at the
description. description ofum. How to
make
after discussing the parameters of aum
yesterday discussing
with what a person may make. Today the
author takes us into
[Silence]
We have a a misprint here.
here we have
who says that one day I
fell into janaba. I was in a state of
janaba and I was unable to source water
to to bathe.
And so I
he attempted in his attempt to make
he says I essentially rolled around and
dusted myself out
and then I made salah.
And so I then later mentioned this to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam meaning
he mentioned
how he made or how he made
he said
and so the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
responded and said it was enough for you
to do this. And so then the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam
struck
the ground with his two hands and then
he blew into his hands, wiped over his
face and over his two hands from the
wrist. Okay? So he did this,
right?
And the reason why he blew into his
hands is because
wherever he was, it's possible that
there was some thorns or something from
the desert that were in the ground. So,
you know, he's not going to So, the
light blow into the hands is to get all
the, you know, big pieces, thorns,
whatever it is, out of the hands. And
then he wiped his face and his hands
this.
I just made
right
you know a simulation of is what I
just did. So he struck the ground.
He blew into his hands. Do you have to
blow into your hands? No. That's not
part of
that is only if there's some things
stuck to your hands, right? that you
don't want on your face. Okay. So, he he
hit the ground once, not three times,
just once.
Then he if there's anything stuck to the
hands, you can blow or you can dust it
off that. And then the face, the
same place you would wipe.
And then the right hand
and the left hand.
That's it.
Do you have to do between the fingers?
You sure you don't have to make sure
that you get it between the fingers and
the knuckles? Huh? Do you have to scrub
them together? Should you put it inside
of your beard? Okay. None of that is
part of that is part of
right
is that what I just showed you. Nothing
more, nothing less. Right? in if there's
anything if there's not wipe the face
and the hands. That's it. That's the
So the prophet
showed him how to do that.
forch.
[Silence]
An important point that the author
mentions here is that
takes the place of wudoo, right? It
takes the place of wudoo under certain
circumstances. Therefore, what is what
invalidates woo is what invalidates
nothing else. Therefore,
a person may make
before the time for a salah is in. They
do not have to remake for each salah. As
long as they have not done anything,
that would invalidate their wudoo. The
only thing that wudoo and differ on. The
only thing that wudoo and differ on
is
that
immediately becomes invalid as soon as a
person is able to use water again.
That's the only difference. The only
difference because some of the mention
that a person has to use
has to make for each salah that he
wishes to pray. So if a person were to
have made
for say and then made salah
then when the time of comes in they have
to make again because is a temporary
thing that stops with the end of each
time for prayer. But there's no evidence
for this
takes the place of wudoo. And so just as
you do not have to make woo each time a
new time for prayer comes in, you do not
have to make more than once unless
unless you have broken your wudoo or
that that equivalent of wudoo
use the restroom or any of the
invalidators of woo then you would make
teum again. Otherwise the same rulings
go as for woo form. Why? Because takes
its place. And the same thing goes
forid. Let's say a person is in a state
of janaba. They do not have access to
water. They're unable to use water. They
make
right. They make
now they pray. What about touching or
handling the mus? Same ruling. You may
now touch and handle the mus. What about
making? The same thing. You may now make
anything that
is for is for in the absence of water or
in the instance in which water is not
an option.
Someone here gave me the flute. Was it
you? You? I'm going to find whoever bit
you. Whatever disc.